im vorfeld des nato-gipfels 2018 bestand
bei vielen teilnehmern großes unbehagen
den us-präsident trump hatte mit
kritischen bemerkungen und vorwürfen die
stimmung kräftig angeheizt
heute in vechta kompakt was bleibt vom
nato-gipfel 2018
[Musik]
vor dem treffen im juli hatte donald
trump peter scharfe kritik an den
niedrigen verteidigungsbudgets der
europäischen partner geübt er warf ihnen
vor seit jahrzehnten auf kosten der usa
zu sein
der us-präsident hatte außerdem für
verunsicherung gesorgt weil er sich
nicht klar zur beistandspflicht bekannte
sogar ein rückzug der usa aus der nato
und den abzug der us soldaten aus
deutschland standen im raum
doch letztlich kam es anders so meinte
deutschlands verteidigungsministerin
ursula van der leyen nach dem gipfel das
ergebnis richtig gut sie sprach von
einer sternstunde der nato was sind nun
die wesentlichen ergebnisse des gipfels
auf strategischer ebene die nato-partner
bekräftigten die beistandsverpflichtung
auch im atombereich an der nuklearen
abschreckung jetzt festgehalten
atomwaffen bleiben in europa stationiert
die partner wiederholen das bekenntnis
zur erhöhung der verteidigungsbudgets
auf 2% bis 2024 und die eu wird als
besonders wichtiger partner
hervorgehoben
auf operativer ebene wurde beschlossen
die aufstellung von zwei neuen kommenden
um rasch kräfte über den atlantik nach
europa bringen und drucken innerhalb
europas schnell verlegen zu können
weiters der aufbau eines cyber space
operations centers in belgien und das
engagement auf dem westbalkan bleibt
aufrecht als besonderes signal die
erhöhung der reaktionsfähigkeit durch
die formeln viermal 30 die sogenannten
for cities 30 mechanisierte bataillone
30 kampf geschwader sowie 30
kriegsschiffe sollen binnen 30 tagen in
europa verfügbar sein
viele maßnahmen orientieren sich primär
an russland und dessen blitzartiger
annexion der green 2014 überraschungen
dieser art soll durch die erhöhung der
reaktionsfähigkeit begegnet werden
können
generell wird russland eine
destabilisierende wirkung in seinem
umfeld und hybride kriegsführung wie zum
beispiel wahlbeeinflussung vorgeworfen
wie ist der gipfel nun zu bewerten
folgendes festzuhalten
man war sich in allen wesentlichen
punkten ein
was als zeichen der geschlossenheit zu
werten ist die nato will wieder stärker
in operative kapazitäten investieren
die usa haben klargestellt dass sie ihr
engagement in europa deutlich erhöhen
werden
so sollen die mittel für nato
verteidigungsmaßnahmen in europa von 3,4
milliarden dollar 2017 auf 6 05 2009/10
beinahe verdoppelt werden die nato
versteht sich unverändert als die
militärische allianz zur verteidigung
europas der eu wird daher eher die rolle
eines krisenmanagers und nicht einer
verteidigungsallianz zugeschrieben
was bleibt daher von nato gipfels das
treffen brachte eine inhalts volle
abschluss erklärung und dürfte zur
beruhigung vor allem der östlichen
mitgliedstaaten beitragen
unabhängig davon besteht eine gewisse
verunsicherung über die tatsächliche
verlässlichkeit der usa als wichtigster
und stärkste nato- partner der ehemalige
general sekretär manfred wörner hat
einmal gesagt das höchste gut der nato
ist ihre glaubwürdigkeit durch gerade
diese hat einerseits unter der
politischen rhetorik des amtierenden
us-präsidenten andererseits unter den
mangelnden verteidigungsanstrengungen
ihre mitglieder in den letzten 20 jahren
deutlich gelitten
der erfolg des gipfels 2018 wird der
daran zu messen sein ob die beschlüsse
umgesetzt werden und ob die
glaubwürdigkeit der nato wieder steckt
[Musik]